[Musik]
ich wusste die sache werde zwischen rom
und südamerika ausgemacht werden
in dem moment als mein vater nach rom
ging und sich die route änderte er also
das geld nicht in der bank oder
brasilien rom hat roma sondern in diesem
büro in lugano in der schweiz ein zahlen
ging hatte mir klar dass er vorsichtig
ausgedrückt nicht mit ganz normalen
unternehmen zusammenarbeitet
[Musik]
ist ein wichtiger knotenpunkt da wir den
internationalen kokain hatte
es gibt keine andere handelsware mit der
man so viel garantierten profit machen
kann wie mit kokain
drogenschmuggel bereichert sich
vornehmlich täter angeht
auf diesem markt hat sie vor allem im
hinblick auf schmuggel und handel ein
enormes monopol
[Musik]
am morgen des 18 juni 2015 wurde cosimo
tassone aus kalabrien verhaftet er war
eine wichtige figur im internationalen
drogenhandel und anführer einer
verbrecherorganisation die jahrelang in
rom aktiv war bei der razzia wurden
neben ihn 18 weitere verhaftet darunter
mehrere finanzmakler die mutmaßlich für
die geldwäsche zuständig war
[Musik]
es waren besondere ermittlungen
wir hauptsächlich durch sie und nur
wenige andere untersuchungen nicht nur
das netzwerk des illegalen
drogenschmuggels rekonstruieren konnten
sondern auch die wiege der gewaltigen
geldmengen nach verfolgen konnten mit
denen der gewaltige trugen berg der nach
italien gebracht wurde bezahlt worden
im laufe von zwei jahren beschlagnahmte
man mehr als eine tonne des kokains der
organisation von cosimo tassone
teils in deutschland holland belgien und
auch italien im kalabrischen hafen von
gioia tauro
2015 legten in gioia tauro
1400 frachter mit etwa 1,6 millionen
containern an
wir suchen nach containern in denen
drogen versteckt sind
dabei sind uns schon gewaltige funde ins
netz gegangen
erst kürzlich fand eine beschlagnahmung
stadt in einem container voller
aluminiumbleche fanden wir
beispielsweise kokain
weitere 167 kilogramm fanden wir in
einem container mit banane
man könnte sagen die schmuggler werden
einfallsreicher also müssen wir uns
anstrengen um mit ihnen schritt halten
zu können
wir müssen also mit der zeit gehen
wie viel kilo insgesamt 220
bestimmt alles sicher
warum wir nicht hier dann gehen
sie
was machen
scheint als wüssten sie bescheid sie
stehen uns im weg
[Musik]
sie haben zwei kisten gefunden sie
wussten bescheid mist
zwei mitglieder der gruppe aus rom waren
verwanzt worden
am 29 märz 2014 bereiteten sich
personnes männer vor die lieferung zu
empfangen als ihnen die guardia di
finanza zuvor kam und 220 kilogramm
kokain beschlagnahmt
der verlust verärgerte ihren anführer
und machte ihn misstrauisch
[Musik]
also habt ihr es große halle ist dass
handys beschlagnahmt
ich habe euch zwei millionen euro
geschenkt
das logistikzentrum der organisation war
ein haus am stadtrand von rom in das die
bandenmitglieder die gewaltigen gewinne
des drogenhandels brachten dort
verteilten sie mit hilfe einiger
finanzmakler die über jeden verdacht
erhaben waren jede woche hunderttausende
euro auf verschiedene geldwäsche
operationen
hier verzeichneten zwar nur ein paar
wenige begegnungen büroangestellten die
aber sehr wichtig waren
im hintergrund konnten wir außerdem
immer wieder das geräusch von
geldzählmaschine aufnehmen
das geräusch begleitete uns bei unserer
abhöraktion jeden tag sind die
wahlkampagne
das geld
aus einer möglichen ort
wann kommt es hier in brasilien an
einer woche
in dollar ja okay ich weiß an wen ich
mich wenden was du kannst du ihn trauern
wir hatten mal einen fall in dem wir
sieben millionen investiert hatten ein
mann und eine frau kamen und die frau
verschwand mit dem geld
ich ging zu ihrer familie und nahm ihre
kinder mit zwei stunden später genau
zwei stunden später stand sie da und
brachte zurück
der tassone clan investierte den erlös
des drogenschmuggels in südamerika in
mehr kokain ein teufelskreis mit
dutzenden operationen jeden monat
den ermittlern gelang es im mai 2014
eine davon über 1,4 millionen euro
zurück zu verfallen
für dieses geschäft wandte sich dass
klein überhaupt an einen finanzberater
aus der toskana der seine kinder daran
beteiligt
war mein vater war schon immer in der
finanz branche tätig
er war zwar ein ruhestand
arbeitete immer noch selbstständig als
berater für einen kunden dessen
internationale finanzgeschäfte er
beaufsichtigt
dieser kunde bot ihm ein geschäft in
südamerika
sollte geld für einige investitionen
zusammen mit soweit ich weiss
immobiliengeschäfte nach
brasilien zu erklärte es eine zumindest
mein vater
die rolle des vaters ist hierbei
besonders zu betonen es gab anfangs
keine absprache darüber wie der transfer
vonstatten gehen sollte
das geld sollte in rom ankommen und dort
bei der banco do brasil eingezahlt
werden
von dort aus sollte es bei überweisungen
zur banco do brasil in sao paulo
gelangen
wir reden von insgesamt fast 1,5
millionen euro ganz klar ein verstoß
gegen das geldwäschegesetz
sie könnten es nicht auf einmal
überweisen also suchten sie andere
lösungen
sie brauchten eine sichere lösung um das
geld auf einen schlag übertragen zu
können
eine überweisung der banco do brasil war
ausgeschlossen
also überlegten sie das geld physisch
von rom in die schweiz und von dort nach
brasilien zu bringen
letztendlich liegt der vater das geld in
sein auto und fuhr an die schweizer
grenze
hier kamen zwei schmuggler ins spiel die
die 1,4 millionen euro in zwei koffern
entgegennahmen und die grenze zur
schweiz unbehelligt überquerten dort
nahm der mittelsmann die koffer wieder
an sich
von dort aus machte sich mein klient
daran den gesamtbetrag bei der agentur
wie war in lugano abzugeben
[Musik]
er zahlte das geld ein und bekam eine
rechnung kam okay
ihm war zuvor versichert worden dies sei
ein sicherer ort um eine solche
operation durchzuführen
alles würde gut gehen und die person die
das geld an nahm wäre diese art vorgang
ohnehin gewohnt
wir nahmen das geld an
das war
mein klient kanti nicht aber es hieß er
würde sich um den schritt von der
schweiz nach südamerika kümmern
[Musik]
ich verfolge einen ansatz bei dem die
nachhaltigkeit im mittelpunkt des
geschäftsmodells steht
ich möchte eine große strategie
entwickeln eine echte energie mischung
angefangen bei unserem kerngeschäft im
ölsektor
rafaeli tanja k ist ein ingenieur aus
bellinzona und hat eine beachtliche
berufliche und politische karriere
hinter sich als präsident der liberalen
partei in bellinzona kandidat für den
grossen rat und verwalter des
energieunternehmens von tessin war er
teil einiger bedeutender energie und öl
unternehmen italiens
in gewisser weise geht alles auf die
familienverhältnisse zurück die
zusammenkunft zweier sich ergänzender
auf der einen seite die erfahrung des
internationalen managers raffael
auf der anderen seite der junge
ingenieur mit viel wachstumspotenzial
[Musik]
2009 gründete raffaele toni egger in
tessin die viva gruppe woran auch sein
cousin flavio petralia kurzzeitig
beteiligt war
der gruppe gehörten mehrere firmen an
vornehmlich im immobilien und
energiesektor
ihre internetpräsenz zufolge gehört dem
unternehmen auch die geldtransfer
agentur viva transfer an deren
eingetragener direktor rafael tonia kos
ehefrau ist
viva transfer nikos mutter sohnes 1,4
millionen euro entgegen
wie wird transfer war das unternehmen
der gruppe dass ich mit geldtransfer
befasste im tagesgeschäft konnte ich
beobachten wie verschiedenste personen
ihr geld brachten das dann sortiert und
über diverse banken ins empfängerland
überwiesen
insbesondere brasilien blieb mir dabei
im gedächtnis
von allen unternehmen der gruppe machte
viva transfer sicher mit den höchsten
gewinn
jacke hatte sich im ausland etabliert
und war ihr nicht allzu bekannt
doch war eine feste größe im
energiebereich und bei erneuerbaren
energien in ihrer not wolle dann kam er
zurück er war genau die person mit der
wir die jüngeren grüne liberalen
überzeugen wollen
[Musik]
2011 kehrte raffaele toni egger als
kandidat der liberalen in die politik
zurück
seine kandidatur dauerte jedoch nur
wenige tage bevor er aufgrund
angeblicher machenschaften bezüglich
seiner früheren arbeit im energiesektor
zurücktreten musste obwohl keine
untersuchung gegen ihn lief
wir waren alle überrascht
die demente so erst machte die
angelegenheit groß schlagzeilen und dann
verpuffte sie im nichts
[Musik]
niemand liebt lange in dem unternehmen
warum verließen sie die firma
okay ich bin nicht aufgrund
offensichtlicher probleme gegangen
sondern aufgrund unterschiedlicher
strategischer ansichten
für den sei die positive es ging dabei
aber nicht so sehr darum wer jetzt recht
hat
quito
colocci wie wir es in den letzten
monaten sah ich eine verlagerung des
fokus auf die aktivitäten in brasilien
statt derer in tessin wo ich mich
eigentlich beruflich wohler und und auch
vernetzter fühlte
[Musik]
raffaele toni egger lehnte eine aussage
zu laufenden ermittlungen wegen des
verdachts auf geldwäsche ab sein anwalt
wies darauf hin dass weder in der
schweiz noch in italien gegen ihn
ermittelt wurde und dass raffael ton
jacke und seine frau nach wie vor als
unschuldig gelten
es ist unstrittig dass 1,4 millionen
euro über den schweizer
finanzdienstleister viva transfer von
italien nach brasilien gelang
der geldwäsche gesetze sind
mittelsmänner verpflichtet bei
verdachtsfällen den ursprung des geldes
und den empfänger offenzulegen
es ist unklar ob das in diesem fall
geschah da die geldwäsche behörde der
schweiz eine aussage verweigerte
ich kann mir kaum vorstellen dass jemand
der einer anderen person 1,4 millionen
euro in bar liefert dabei allen
beteiligten fein säuberlich erklärt wo
das geld herkommt wo es hin soll und wer
dahinter steckt
in der branche wissen sowieso alle
bescheid was los ist
das problem ist auch die art wie das
geld geliefert wurde nämlich in bar
wir konnten uns aber nicht direkt damit
befassen wie das geld in tessin
angenommen von schätzt
ihr kümmert und stattdessen um die die
es dorthin brachten soweit es eben in
unserer gerichtsbarkeit viel
sie schickten ein rechtshilfegesuch in
die schweiz kam eine antwort
das ist teil einer laufenden ermittlung
sie können es nicht sagen nicht im
moment sind bezüglich laufender
ermittlungen zur verschwiegenheit
verpflichtet
ebenso wie unsere schweizer kollegen
[Musik]
wir sollten den behörden in der schweiz
eine anfrage bezüglich der laufenden
ermittlungen in tessin erhielten aber
keine antwort
es bleibt die tatsache dass die
italienischen mittelsmänner vor gericht
eine absprache treffen wollen
für sie entwickelte sich die affäre zu
einem echten albtrauf bei
unseren ermittlungen stellten wir fest
dass ein angehöriger eines mittels manz
in brasilien als geisel genommen worden
war und erst nach abschluss der
überweisung des geldes frei gelassen
werden sollte
[Musik]
sein sohn war nach brasilien geflogen wo
er in ein hotelzimmer gebracht wurde
dass er nicht verlassen durfte die
brasilianische bank grünes licht gab
ihre erwartungen wurden nicht erfüllt
das geld kam nicht auf einmal an sondern
in kleinen portionen was tassone und
seine männer erzählte
sie verdächtigt sie sofort
aus einem einwöchigen aufenthalt in
brasilien wurde ein monat
erfuhr dass personnes männer in italien
seinen vater und seinen bruder immer
mehr unter druck setzt
die operation lief nicht wie geplant da
nicht die erwartete summe überwiesen
wurde die auch vereinbart worden war
erst kam viel weniger geld in südamerika
ich wollte dem eigentümer des geldes
sofort beweisen dass sich über nichts
bescheid wusste
als mein vater und auch mein bruder in
brasilien nichts mit einem möglichen
betrugsversuch zu tun hätten
seitdem stark dass er den rest des
geldes her schaffen soll
schneide ich ihm den kopf ab
ich werde sich abschlachten
sie haben sich mit den falschen angelegt
wenn sie uns für einfache unternehmer
halten
sie waren alles andere als umgänglich
und wurden verbal wie körperlich
aggressiv
das bereitete meinen klienten sorgen die
hamas wird sehr komisch aber global
anke pipke ihnen wurde gesagt man hätte
das geld ihrer familie gegeben
es war schon ein besonderer
menschenschlag
sie stellten sich mehr und mehr als
verbrecher heraus versuchten ihnen angst
zu machen und sie unter druck zu setzen
nehmen sie ihre verwandten erwähnten
noch während der bruder in brasilien war
gingen mein klient zweimal in die
schweiz um nachzuvollziehen was genau
geschehen war und es seinen peinigern
erklären zu können nichts anderes waren
sie schließlich
einer der fahrten war ich mit jemandem
aus rom unterwegs
ich wollte mehr über sie erfahren und
beweisen und dass es keine geheimen
abmachungen zwischen meinem vater und
der agentur in lugano person
zu dem zeitpunkt war bereits alles
möglich
mein vater hatte die rechnung aber sie
sagten sie kann hier nicht wissen ob wir
nicht eine absprache mit der agentur
gemacht
ich versuchte sie davon zu überzeugen
dass mein vater nicht einen euro selbst
eingesteckt hatte
ich sprach zweimal mit der frau des
eigentümers und traf auch ihn selbst
einmal
ich bekam die belege der sogenannten
vermittlung das waren letztendlich die
überweisungen aus der schweiz nach
brasilien
einschließlich aller verwendeten
wechselkurse und wären
sie sagten eine überweisung in einem
schritt wäre nicht möglich gewesen weil
so schick um sie mehrere überweisungen
weil die gesetze es nicht anders
zuließen
sie redeten von kommissionen und
beteiligungen das alles wurde von tanja
k verwaltet
letztendlich gelangte nicht alles geld
nach brasilien
400.000 euro fehlten
wir wissen bis heute nicht was daraus
geworden ist
was wurde aus dem rest des geldes dass
cosimo tassone über mittelsmänner nach
lugano schöpfen ließ
vielleicht kann das gerichtsverfahren
das im juni in italien zu einem ende
kommen sollte aufschluss darüber geben
raffaele de jager ist jedenfalls nicht
unter den angeklagten
[Musik]
das organisierte verbrechen ist nicht in
der lage dieses geld zu überweisen
das
bedeutet dass sie selbst beim
kokainhandel üblicherweise eine illegale
angelegenheit auf professionelle hilfe
angewiesen sind um ihr geld bewegen zu
können
und dass diese profis bereit sind ihnen
dabei zu helfen
hier ging es um 1,4 millionen euro in
bar
wir sollten auf keinen fall vergessen
dass das geld ohne die bereitwillige
hilfe der identifizierten finanzprofis
in rom geblieben wäre
es hätte nie seinen weg nach brasilien
gefunden
[Musik]